[Music]
on Sunday morning Fran I joined mayor
nan Whaley her husband Sam
lieutenant Matt Dickie the Dayton police
department to tour the Oregon district
for the shooting took place it's the
morning that I will never forget crime
scene tape bullet markings blood and
probably the most poignant thing was a
vendor's cart with food still on it
where he had been shot down nine people
went out on that beautiful Saturday
evening early Sunday morning nine people
who did not come home they left their
families they left their friends
grieving a loss that is really
impossible to comprehend that night
Sunday night friend I went back to the
Oregon district in Dayton to attend a
prayer vigil it was a beautiful peaceful
night justice it had been the night
before a great Ohio summer night his
friend I climbed up to the platform and
we looked out it was amazing the number
of people who were there as far as we
could see there were people literally
down the street
a testament to the resiliency of Dayton
and the great Miami Valley some in the
crowd were angry in fact I'm sure
everybody was angry because I tell you
Fran and I were angry and we are angry
and they should be mangry I understand
that anger for it's impossible to make
sense out of what is senseless some
chanted do something and they were
absolutely right we must do something
and that is exactly what we are going to
do today I'm announcing the following
initiatives the following actions number
one safety protection orders we have to
empower people to get help for family or
loved ones who may be a danger to
themselves or a danger to others people
who have mental health challenges
alcohol or drug problems that violent
tendencies and and have access to
firearms deadly combination police and
sheriff's deputies also need to be able
to activate the criminal justice system
when they find an individual in that
situation when they find someone who is
in danger who is a danger to themselves
or who's a danger to others and as
access to a gun that's why today I'm
asking the legislature to pass a law to
allow courts to issue safety protection
orders now I'm going to explain this in
detail
because details are important these
orders which would be grand upon clear
and convincing evidence would allow the
removal of firearms from potentially
dangerous individuals and get them the
mental health treatment that they need
get them whatever help that they need
individuals could be subject to a safety
protection order if they present an
imminent risk of injury to themselves
suicide for example or they present that
risk to another person because of mental
health issues because of drug dependency
chronic alcoholism or other serious
conditions these concerns of course must
our Constitution demands it be balanced
against the individuals right to keep
and bear arms and their due process
rights my proposal will allow the state
of Ohio to file for temporary orders a
hearing it under my proposal this
ultimately will be up to the General
Assembly a hearing would under this
proposal be held within three days of
the filing or sooner the individual
would have all the traditional due
process rights the temporary order could
be granted a temporary order could be
granted if the state shows by probable
cause that person is a danger to
themselves or others and has access to
firearms if the temporary order is
granted it would require the person to
surrender all firearms to law
enforcement if granted a hearing would
then be held a second hearing within 14
days do Turman if an extended safety
protection order should be granted in
this hearing all the same traditional
due process rights would apply
the court was then find by clear and
convincing evidence that the person is a
danger to themselves or to others
the extended order would be issued under
an extended safety protection order as
we envision it the court would order a
mental health assessment the individual
would be required to undergo any
recommended treatment the individual
prohibited from purchasing or possessing
firearms and any firearm from the
temporary order would continue to be
withheld from that individual in Luud
law enforcement in lieu of law
enforcement keeping the firearms an
individual could could have them sold on
their behalf to a federally licensed
firearm dealer extended orders would
last for a period of six months and
could be extended with another petition
and another human an individual could
apply to the court any time after three
months for return of his firearms only
if the person could prove by clear and
convincing evidence that they were no
longer a danger to themselves or others
that is during that period of time
initiative number two we must have
increased access to the citizens of the
state of Ohio for the citizens of the
state of Ohio to our state psychiatric
hospital we have a problem in this state
we have a problem with people who are
not violent who have been sent there by
a court who could be sent someplace else
and these individuals are occupying
space that we urgently need today and
I'm calling on the General Assembly to
take action in this area inpatient
psychiatric care is limited in Ohio
making it difficult for individuals and
families to access the level of care
when it is needed over the past several
years
Ohio's state psychiatric hospital
capacity
has become predominantly used by
patients who are court-ordered to the
hospital for restoration to competency
to stand trial this week for example 79
percent of the adults in our state
psychiatric hospitals are court-ordered
there many of these patients are
nonviolent offenders many are
misdemeanors they are they're simply in
the hospital pursuant to a court order
to learn how the court process works
it's the only reason to they are surely
together we can find another place for
these individuals to obtain that help
that help being understanding how the
court system works so they can proceed
with trial this education certainly can
be done outside of these hospitals
freeing up critical beds for people who
in fact do need hospitalization the
people I'm talking about coming out of
the hospital or people who don't need
impatient sight here at your care well
there are other people in Ohio who
clearly do to accomplish this the
General Assembly will need to pass
changes to the Revised Code to create a
community-based misdemeanour competency
restoration process
I'm calling on the legislature today to
do that action number three early
intervention schools
we have a serious mental health crisis
among many of our children in the state
of Ohio today it is growing worse so
many of our children have been
negatively impacted by trauma the trauma
can take many forms can be living an
addicted parent it can be seeing
violence on the streets seeing violence
in the home it can be all the problems
that come from Horrible poverty the
result is that the suicide rate among
our young people today breaks your heart
they just breaks your heart all the
facts of the Dayton tragedy are not yet
known and they will be coming out in the
days and weeks ahead but it is clear
that the assailant while in high school
clearly exhibited antisocial behaviors
antisocial behaviors that should have
alerted anyone who knew about them that
there was a problem a serious problem
with this high school student and told
by the specialists that half of mental
health conditions problems start by the
age of 14 half and 75% are identified by
age 24 providing early intervention
helps young people recover more quickly
and have better outcomes with their
education it helps them build positive
relationships with family and friends
and helps them have healthier lives
throughout adulthood
as part of the budget that has been
approved by the General Assembly and I
know if Senate President Lee Ralph Hoff
was was here I was told a moment ago
Thank You senator Ford for joining us
appreciate it very much I talked to the
speaker yesterday as well and the two
minority leaders about what I was going
to present I want to thank the General
Assembly under this budget we are
investing 675 million dollars for what
we are calling wraparound services these
clearly can be used and it's our intent
for many of them much of them to be used
for mental health services for children
these are for addressing social
emotional challenges their kids are
facing from suicide prevention to the
effects of substance use crisis and all
these things all these things teachers
tell me impact their ability to teach
the child in the classroom by providing
funds to every school district these
schools can design tailored programs
working with their local mental health
providers or other social service
agencies to help these kids earlier in
life the earlier that we can intervene
in children's lives and make a positive
difference clearly the better it is
action item number four we are also
increasing access under this budget and
again I thank the general assembly to
behavioral health professionals in our
schools with 15 million dollars in
Medicaid funding to provide telehealth
mental health services to students so
that no matter where a child lives in
the state of Ohio no matter how remote
it is they have access to high-quality
mental health care this coupled with the
wraparound services will make a huge
huge difference let me move to action
item number five communities know their
kids the best the Ohio Department mental
health and addiction services will be
working in a more concentrated effort
we'll be working with communities to
increase knowledge of risk factors to
help parents identify when their child
is showing signs of a mental illness the
Ohio Department of Mental Health and
Addiction Services will also share
screen tools with clinicians help
connect community-based services and
link parents families and schools with
proven supports and strategies to manage
wellness over the child's lifetime
I am number 6 background checks I'm
asking the General Assembly to pass a
law that requires background checks for
all firearm sales in the state of Ohio
with the exception for guests between
family members and certain other limited
uses
number seven an unbelievably high number
of Ohio citizens are being killed as a
result of chronic gun violence in the
streets and in neighborhoods of our
cities mayor thank you for being here
well most Americans there who talked
about last night why we mourn those who
are killed in Dayton
we should not forget the other Ohio
citizens our citizens are brothers and
sisters that includes many times
children who are innocent victims of
random violence and not so random
violence we cannot forget those
individuals who are dying every day in
our cities and across our state we have
to deal with those individuals who are
inflicting that violence law enforcement
officers have told me for years that the
majority of violence in a community is
being perpetuated by a relatively small
number of individuals we just study a
few years ago which absolutely confirmed
that going back to 1977 the vast
majority of criminals in this state are
not do not commit violent crime
we must target those who commit the
violent crime we must go after them we
must take them out of our communities
far too often criminals who have
absolutely no right under Ohio law to
possess a gun are using guns nonetheless
that's who we have to go after the
criminals this must stop so I'm asking
the General Assembly to increase
penalties on violent felons who continue
to illegally possess or use guns
number eight illegal possession of a
firearm by a violent felon we must
increase penalties for violence and
other people who are found with a gun
that they do not have the legal right to
possess the crime of having weapons
while
a disability which is what it's called
is currently a third degree felony
punishable by maximum of three years in
prison I believe that this is a crime
that for a first offense should be a
second-degree felony
second-degree felony punishable by two
to eight years in prison and for a
subsequent offense should be a
first-degree felony which is 3 to 5 3 to
11 year excuse me
item number nine possession of firearm
while committing a felony we should
increase penalties for people who commit
felonies with a firearm or who's that's
a firearm while committing a felony
current law allows for an additional
penalty of one year when a person
possesses a firearm while committing a
felony this should be increased to a
mandatory additional one to three years
I'm 10 using or brandishing a firearm
while committing a felony we must
increase penalties for using a
brandishing a weapon when committing
felony current law allows for an
additional penalty of 3 years if a
person uses a brandishes a firearm while
committing a felony this should be
increased at a minimum to a mandatory
three to five years in prison again
these are my recommendations to the
General Assembly the General Assembly
will I hope act upon all of them and
exercise their judgment on these I am
number 11 the problem of straw
purchasers we must increase penalties
for those who buy guns illegally for
other people a practice known as straw
purchasing now straw purchasing is
illegal under both Ohio and federal law
today however these well the Ohio law
must be toughened and I intend to do
that
all too often firearms obtained through
these straw purchases are used in
serious violent offenses I am asking the
General Assembly to increase the
penalties for those who purchase a gun
illegally for another person today the
illegal purchaser of a firearm a straw
purchaser this is the person who
actually purchase it for the other
person
through a straw purchase that penalty is
a third-degree felony punishable up to
three years in prison we must increase
the penalty for a straw purchaser to at
least a second-degree felony punishable
by 2 to 8 years in prison
number 12 I'm also asking the General
Assembly to increase increase the
penalty for a person who possesses a
firearm this is the person who the straw
purchase who got the firearm and when
they get that farm that they know that
they know was obtained through an
illegal or fraudulent purchase when a
person possesses a firearm they know was
fraudulently obtained that person should
be punished in the same manner as the
person who bought the firearm an F 2 2
to 8 years number 13 we should increase
penalties for people who illegally
illegally furnished firearms to minors
Ohio law provides very well for father
to give that gun to the son this is done
all the time we have hunters but that's
not what we're talking about we'd find
too many of our kids are carrying guns
on the streets often with tragic
consequences so adults through the
illegally furnished firearms to minors
must be held accountable
today improperly furnishing a firearm to
a minor is only a fifth degree felony up
to 12 months in prison I'm asking the
General Assembly to make the crime at
least a third degree felony punishable
by up to three years in prison action
item 14 school tip line we are expanding
our school safety tip line where kids
and adults can call or text anonymously
with tips about potential school
violence
I'm calling on Ohio ones today to
utilize that tip line the number is
eight four four seven two three three
seven six four eight four four seven two
three three seven six four we will have
that on our website
Tom it'll be on the public safety
website I believe as well is and again
we're asking for people to step up you
see something when you hear something do
something we want to make sure people
understand that they have the ability to
make that call they can certainly always
call their local police they can call
their local sheriff call somebody so
we're expanding that school safety tip
line let me talk about the world of
social media while each one of the mass
shooting tragedies in this country is
the same and but it's also different and
the lessons that we learn from one
should be applied and it should be
cumulative for the lessons we learn from
all but one things that we have seen is
the time after time the assailant when
you go back you see on social media the
signs were there they were there we
should have caught
in the 24/7 world social media threats
can and do arise at any time our hub is
what's called at the Ohio Department of
Public Safety is expanding I told them
to expand their ability to monitor and
track potential threats on social media
and to share that information with local
law enforcement and with schools we now
have the ability through software to
target specific phrases specific words
this is not that we're modern everybody
social media but we're looking for that
sign from that violent offender that
might save a life or ten lives we will
be in touch when we find things with the
local schools and local law enforcement
partners
I am Sept 16 the budget that was
approved by this General Assembly also
includes nearly nine million dollars to
help harden soft targets like nonprofits
and religious organizations to make
their facilities more secure
we're seeing too much hate and we're
seeing hate targeted at religious groups
and that is wrong
this action General Assembly took is to
help them help them prepare help them
avoid tragedy item 17 working closely
with Sandy Hook promise Ohio schools are
now implementing know the signs safety
assessment intervention program across
the state to know the signs safety
assessment intervention program this
program equipped school staff with
knowledge and skills to identify
potential threats of violent action and
to take steps to intervene currently
there are 23 training dates already
scheduled again I would appeal to our
schools not had that training go out
take advantage of that take advantage of
that training I know also that the
Attorney General has additional training
in other areas that could be helpful for
schools our state is heartbroken the
fabric of our society has been torn we
are shrouded in deep sadness the
needless loss of lives that occur in
Dayton
as Freya and I were there Sunday I
thought about the parents who had lost
children children who had lost parents
friends who had lost friends now more
than ever we need to come together we
must come together as the much larger
Ohio family because when one family
grieves all of us grief we have an
obligation to each other we have an
obligation to include not exclude people
we have an obligation to help others we
have an obligation to look out for each
other
someone is showing signs of struggle
problem we must help and we must not
turn away there is a saying that and I
quote tragedy should be utilized as a
source of strength and quote no matter
what sort of difficulties or how painful
the experiences experience is if we lose
hope that's a real disaster
end of quote so now is our time to be
strong now is our time as a state to
come together Democrats Republicans
liberals conservatives everybody come
together now I'm calling on everyone to
do that
look we might have some differences we
should never forget that what holds us
together as Americans as Ohioans is so
much greater than any differences look
we can do this we can do the things that
I outlined today we will do them we can
do meaningful things to protect lives it
won't be easy and although it is dark
now the Sun will shine again as we find
the Grace in the glory and each new
sunrise and the hope of each new day I
believe in this state I believe in its
people we can come together we can come
together to do these things to save
lives
let me just add there's no magic about
these proposals there's no guarantees in
life if we do these they're gonna be
violent someplace in the country well we
know there's going to be some violence
it's the world we live in we understand
but I can tell you this if we do these
things it will matter if we do these
things it will make us safer each one of
these by themselves is not going to
solve all the problems but I believe in
my heart that each and every one of them
will help each and every one of them
will lessen the chance of violence
each and every one of them will make
this a better state and make this a
stronger state the work that we have
ahead of us though is not just in these
proposals and if you look at these
proposals quite frankly particularly in
the area of mental health where we have
a crisis it's going to be the day-to-day
slog the day-to-day work that is going
to make the difference it's the blocking
and the tackling I'm not the football
player John is but it's it's you've got
do it every single day but I can tell
you if we're committed to do this we can
do it if we're committed to making sure
young kids have more access to mental
health if we're committed to reducing
the trauma that they experienced we can
make a big big difference
let me say something to my home the
Miami Valley and to the specifically to
the people in Dayton we will spend the
next few days burying the dead we will
spend the next few days hoping and
helping that those who have been injured
helping them recover praying for them
but the people of Dayton and the people
of Miami Valley are resilient if anybody
has a doubt about that they should have
been there
Sunday night where as far as you could
see your people people holding up
handles people going to the scene of the
crime
and saying we will not be intimidated
pink is a great city
it's a city as we all know the great
history it's a city with a great future
so many great things going on the mayor
and I have talked about this a lot she
and I are both very optimistic about the
future of Dayton as people are resilient
as we've already seen so for the people
of Dayton there are better days ahead
from the people of Miami Valley there
are better days and ahead Sun will come
up there will be opportunities in the
future we will always remember those who
died we will always be scarred by that
but we will do what Ohioans have always
done and that is pushed forward more
happy to respond any questions from the
media
well the things that I've just outlined
they were all in some process but look
we're all human tragedy focuses you and
you know it was time to get him out the
first item that I mentioned as an item
that we've been working on for months we
were that close to getting it done back
close last two days John drove it home
and we got it done so a you know it's
what I hope you know what you hope comes
out of this
it is a renewed energy and renewed sense
that we need to tackle these problems
some of them we're already tackling this
gives us a harder push all of us I think
all of us know how to to do these things
I can't tell you exactly what was in the
governor's proposal Governor Kasich
proposal I will tell you that and we'll
let Johnny answer this in a moment but
we were very careful to try to do
something that wouldn't matter and that
would work but at the same time
something that clearly protected due
process and guaranteed those individuals
due process let me just add one more
thing before I turn to John one things
in answer to the previous question that
I hope comes out of this is once this is
passed by the General Assembly people
know about it and use it each one of us
I think certainly anybody who's been as
close as I have to law enforcement can
come up with examples of where we had
someone who everybody in the town knew
had a problem I think of one guy who had
a law and I won't say where it was but
he had long term mental health problems
everybody knew about he was an alcoholic
and he had an arsenal of guns and
everybody sort of knew the day was
coming but nothing for whatever
different reasons nothing got done so
what I hope comes out of this not only
we passed the law but that people
understand that it can be activated now
due process is there and John Johnny one
thank you trying to address the specific
question what was different is that we
sat down with the Second Amendment
community they are here today we invited
them to be here and to be part of that
process their major concern was is their
due process under the law and this
provision we provide due process under
the law the if somebody is an immediate
threat the police
can remove them that exists in our
current law but then there will be a due
process through the court system that
will then give the ability for any
weapons that the Evangel individual has
to be taken by police but it won't
happen at the police's discretion it
will happen at the order of a judge that
was the primary difference and the
sticking point on these issues and
instead and said so we brought people to
the table to have the discussion to work
it through there will certainly be
discussion about as it goes through the
process but that's the primary
difference between what was what was
referred to as a ranked red flag law and
what we are referring to which is
different than that as a safety
protection order which provides for that
due process and it's also emphasized
excuse me but let me just also emphasize
when we say safety protection order we
kind of wrestled with what to call it
the idea is that you're you know you're
going to eliminate some suicides by
doing this I mean you're gonna help so
it's the public and it's also the
individual sometimes these people are
their own worst enemy and it's just the
way it is so you're going to pretty save
some lives there
you can save some lives out in the
community who else okay this is in our
prepared statement it's what I read that
is that that is the exact process it is
a two-step process but every stage there
is protection and I think it's literally
we can get you my statement it is there
I mean it is a is a process that is
activated it's a process that is
activated initially by a family member
or by the police and I think that's what
so if you have somebody else out in the
community who is seeing this they can go
the place and report that then you start
through the process and there is
basically at what I would call a
temporary order that hearing is between
three days and then you flip right over
into a more permanent order but in both
of those new process has to has to take
place all the due process right across
exam all of all of
of those things so you got yeah you get
service on the person in other words you
have to notify them they have to have
the opportunity to come to court so it's
all the procedures that we are so used
to in a criminal justice system and that
we you know so well know we hope that
judges will put this on a rocket docket
and we'll deal with it and get the
people in and serve them get them served
make sure they have their due process
and get them in there what we are saying
it we hope it happens much senator what
we're saying is the judge would have
three days to do this at first hearing
we would then say after that order and
there's a different standard of proof
there then then you would flip over into
the permit hearing which would have to
be within 14 days yeah John John one I
want to add a practical issue so that
you understand because I spoke with law
enforcement about this I spoke with
people from the secondary management
community we tried to thread the needle
on everybody's concerns but if somebody
is an immediate threat taking their guns
does not remove that threat you need to
remove the person from the situation and
then go through the due process to take
the weapons away if the judge so orders
because you there are many other ways to
commit violence other than with guns and
so if a person is an immediate threat we
need to remove them and either pink slip
them and put them in a and a mental
health facility or put them in jail so
that this process can take place it's
not seizing somebody's property without
due process that was the the stick that
was the issue that couldn't get resolved
in the past we've worked with voices
across the the broad array of concern
and we believe we have those sorted out
and this is heavy
John made a very good point this is this
what we present as John assembling is
heavy on helping that person there's not
punitive
we won't protect them from themselves
going to protect them from hurting
somebody else but if you if you
look at that proposal you know it calls
for help going directly to that
individual and that's that's what it's
very heavy on that and we believe unlike
in the past when it failed that we
brought people together and this can
pass and become law and and begin to be
implemented sooner rather than having
the old fights that ended up in inaction
look there are a lot of issues that we
could talk about there are a lot of
issues that quite candidly if you're
serious about getting results I'm con
results-oriented guy some of these
things have to be done at the federal
level John you want to add anything to
that no I think that's
[Music]
look as I indicated there or a lot of
this was in the works in fact all of it
I think there may not be some exceptions
but I'm not aware of anything that was
not already in the works you know part
of this is I have made this very clear
throughout this crisis that we're going
to do things that matter we're gonna do
things that are constitutional and we're
gonna do things that can get passed so
making sure something can get passed is
a key you'll find after four years or
eight years with me I'm bottom line
results oriented I don't do a whole lot
of things just to be doing them so our
job is to get results our job is to get
something passed and so getting it in
the proper form for example our item
number one which you're just talking
about we needed to make sure that we had
the buy-in that we had the assistance
from the Second Amendment community
because if we presented that bill to
this General Assembly without that the
bill would go nowhere so what I owe the
people the state is results I don't know
um rhetoric rhetoric fine sometimes an
occasion for it but what they want and
what I've heard year after year from the
people of aisle is fix the problems
help us make things better that's what
this proposal does but as far as the
timing of all those that's why we're
trying to get these things in a you know
in a way that we can get them passed by
the General Assembly
IIIi have talked dealing with all four
legislative leaders I had those
conversations yesterday I have said to
them we will get you copies of it I
tried to outline in broad brush strokes
what we were going to do I also said to
them I fully understand that the General
Assembly will do what the General
Assembly does which is is hold hearings
and and look at look at these things but
you know these are all things that I
believe can pass these are all things
that we can get done these are all
things that can will make a difference
these are all things that are
constitutional and it was great it was
great that Larry op Hoff was a great
sign that's the IROC I know he had to go
but he was here and that was a big sign
I talked off all four of the leaders
we started this Tom you want can you
come up tom stick records I want to get
the chronology correct this is this is
not brand new but it's it's going up
light back so you know I talk about my
tree general we start talking about it
yeah we did
thank you Tom sticker at Director of
Public Safety and we did start talking
about this with Attorney General to one
and working on some of these things that
you're a criminal investigation I would
say the difference is we're now being
proactive rather than reactive we've
probably historically been reacting with
social media after an event we you know
go back and take a look at what what we
can find out what we're trying to do now
is be more on the front end of the
prevention side of it again not not the
NSA looking at every every social media
but but looking at those key words and
phrases using software technologies and
trained staff to be on the front end of
these situations there could be yes this
is anybody can do this so you know well
we worry about correctly worrying about
the government state doing it but when
someone puts that out and what were what
we're what we're seeing time after time
after time
is there a warnings with this you know
you see social with almost in every case
you're seeing warnings on the internet
something they're putting up posting you
when you drill down at you see him go
back to this young man it's usually a
young man you see what he was saying in
high school you see social alienation
you see writing things I mean there was
one case a few years ago tragic case
where you know a person in high school I
believe was high school had written
someone must die on the top of their
page well you know teacher said well
that's not good but look these are signs
and this is you need we need to look at
this as a package we need to look at all
the different things because part of
this as I pointed out we had already
started down this pathway there's 675
million dollars
we ask this legislature to give us
wraparound services it was in direct
result to of what we have been seen time
and time again that we're having
children traumatized and they're having
mental health problems and we've got to
deal with those mental health problems
so so a lot of this was moving forward
but you have to look at it
I think holistically in how we help kids
every every single day in some cases
we're going to be able to identify a kid
who's suicidal in other cases we may
identify a young person who is
exhibiting all kinds of bad signs that
in you know a few years or not but not a
few years they'll they'll turn into a
killer so don't come it all comes
together each one is important each one
should be passed I see no reason that
all these cannot be passed I expect the
General Assembly to do his
constitutional duty to look at these
issues to have hold hearings to bring in
interested parties but we have tried to
put together these proposals that are
constitutional that make a difference
and that we think we can get past now
I'm not saying it's gonna be easy I'm
not going to say it's going to be easy
but to get back to a question that was
asked a moment ago in reference to folks
folks in Toledo the momentum that that
it's been created by this horrible
horrible tragedy you know I think is
putting a spotlight on this you're
reporting it more more talk about it
everybody's looking at it more now as
now as it is a window of opportunity for
us to change things to do what we need
to do
thinking of their all look first of all
we don't know all the facts about him
more facts keep coming out as the news
media does the good work it does but the
answer is all of the above if you look
at the combination of all the different
things either that we have already said
in place in motion in this budget that
was for those of you from Ohio was
passed in July in that budget and in the
additional proposals here there's ample
we hope there's ample opportunity to for
someone to speak up to identify and the
key to identification is you have to be
able to do something with it and so one
of the things we heard from teachers is
well we don't have anything we don't
know what to do with it or you know we
need to be tied into the social services
so if you look at where our thoughts are
and again I've gotten some questions
from superintendents about well Hortis
is 675 million dollars over two years
supposed to be spent what can we spend
it on in regard to the wraparound
services the the answer is this is
something you can spend it on and what
we envision you doing is not you know
creating out a whole cloth use those
resources to tap into the local
community resources so the resources
that are already in the community with
the animates board or other ways to get
that so the answer is all all of the
above
look look look Eric every every school
district under this budget will get
money we did what we have done and this
legislature is done and tried to make
sure every school had the resources to
do that and and when you look at it from
that perspective what you do is you
allow the poor school districts with
more poor kids to have more resources
because they don't have other resources
so yes I am I am hopeful and confident
that every school has the ability to do
this we also have money in there we
didn't talk about this but which is
related we also have money in there in
regard to a social-emotional learning
which is we have put under the under the
broad category of how we we help young
people avoid going down the pathway of
addiction so we're gonna talk about that
in there but that's that's a part of
this as well I do not know much about to
visit my understanding is the president
is coming tomorrow
and you know I was invited to be there
I've talked to the mayor about the visit
but I don't know that I don't at this
point know the final details of what
they're what they're going to do was
there a second question yeah
look I think it's always appropriate for
a governor president to go where there
is sorrow to go for people hurting my
understanding of the visit is that's
what it's focused on being here saying
I'm sorry it happened I agree for you
that's part of what life is about and I
think that when the president can do
that it's a good thing and I think it's
part of the responsibility of the
governor the governor says when I go I
said look I represent the people of Ohio
people are grieving all over Ohio for
you the president comes he can say that
about about the country and in both
cases it happens to be true well you're
gonna have to be the judge of that
I don't have a crystal ball but these
are doable proposals these are things
that really will matter these are things
that we can get done not saying it's
easy to get it done but you know we look
at results and what matters is results
and can we do things that will make a
difference that will make our children
safer our communities safer or friends
safer or family safer we look at that
every day I mean that's a you know
that's the the job of the governor as I
said many of these all of these
proposals were in some different phase
and we knew that in some cases we could
do it ourselves through through
executive order or through our agencies
and we down that pathway but we also
knew others we
the system need to go to the general
assembly and to get the General Assembly
to pass them and so this is a window of
opportunity and let's not mess it up
let's not miss this opportunity this is
our opportunity to do to do do these
things thank you for the question since
this tragedy started on Sunday morning I
I've made clear that every one of these
shootings is different everyone's the
same in some respects most of them
involve a person who is marginalized for
whatever reason usually it is a male
usually someone in that range of age but
they're different and if we after a
tragedy only confine ourselves to doing
those things that would have prevented
this tragedy we're missing a real
opportunity so we need to look at all
these tragedies together and quite
candidly we also use this opportunity to
look at other problems that we have that
might be somewhat related for example
you'll see in here proposals that I've
thought about a long time and I tried to
get past when I was the Attorney General
and we didn't really get much past and
you know we've been preparing to take to
the General Assembly having to do with
violent people out in on the streets and
in targeting repeat and vile offenders
so we have an obligation to use this as
an opportunity to pass things and get
things done that are going to save lives
well all these have in common is I am
convinced their implementation will save
lives no magic about any of this I can't
guarantee we won't have other tragedies
but what we have to do is is to continue
to chip away at this and we have to
continue to do things that that make a
difference in that matter so we look at
this not confined if we only confine
ourselves
to the facts of this case we will come
up with a very limited answer to our
bigger problems yeah John the challenge
will have on on the on the whole package
as it relates to guns the difference is
that we focused on keeping guns away
from people who shouldn't have them
either for mental health reasons or
because they've broken the law and can't
legally possess firearms and we did all
that without infringing on the rights of
law-abiding citizens that's why we
worked with the Second Amendment
community that's why they there we've
asked them to be here today
because it's going to take all of us to
get this done and we can't finger-point
and we can't draw lines in the same we
have to bring everybody together to do
it we have to listen to the details and
we have to work together to get this
accomplished and I believe we can't and
what the governor outlined today is that
he's not just focused we're not just
focused on one issue we're broadening
the conversation about a lot of the
brokenness that's out there in our world
today on the mental health front on the
the opioid front and the addiction front
that it is that he has been such a great
champion of you know suicides all of
these things will as a package do a part
play a part of helping to save lives for
people all across the landscape of Ohio
and let me just add one other thing kind
of there's a PS my friends in the mental
health community I think would want me
to point out the obvious which is that
the vast vast vast majority in fact way
over 90% of the people who have a mental
health problem or not violent all and so
you know we need to understand that even
people with severe mental health
problems well over 90% of them are not
violent at all so you know we have to
have a lot of different things coming
together for example for issue before
our item number one comes together but
we part of part of our challenges is is
is
stigmatizing those with a mental health
illness we've got to start treating
people with mental health illness like
that cancer they had some other problem
medical problem that we because it is a
medical problem and we got a that's
something we got to get over and we're
making progress but we got to do it we
got to do a better job and that's part
of what some of these programs are
trying to do I think we need to get this
done first look my position and John
Huston's position in regard to the
second amendment have not changed our
positions on those bills have not
changed but we need to do this because
we need to assure people that these
specific actions are being are being
taken thank you all very much